ta monsieur jacques alain bénisti pour
le groupe l'est républicain merci madame
la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre du développement durable de
l'écologie des transports et jj associés
à cette question que les christian jacob
et l'ensemble des élus de seine-et-marne
madame la ministre le grand paris
express réseau de transport autour de la
capitale est appelé à transformer et
simplifier la vie de millions de
franciliens la loi près de loi dans son
article premier cas chaque fois que le
grand paris express 3 1 rer
il y a création d'une intercommunalité
collection et donc d'une gare c'est le
cas sur l'ensemble du réseau sauf entre
la ligne e et le rer et aligne 15 du
nouveau métro à hauteur de la gare de
bridiers champigny en effet à l'occasion
du conseil interministériel qui abordera
jeudi les arbitrages financiers et
politiques du grand paris express
cette gare est purement et simplement
supprimé la raison évoquée
aucun financement pour les trois
kilomètres de rails supplémentaires en
provenance de seine-et-marne
il est vrai que les crédits initialement
prévu pour son financement ont été
détournés l'europe les initiales pour
financer notamment la nouvelle gare aux
appart à paris qui devait initialement
être financé par le stif
ce sont donc 1 million de seine-et-marne
est et 500000 est val de marnais soit
1,5 million de franciliens qui ne
bénéficieront pas de la correspondance
avec le grand paris
le paradoxe c'est que ces derniers ont
été largement mis à contribution
fiscalement depuis cinq ans sur ce
projet lors manama nice
ma question se résume par conséquent à
une demande une demande vital pour ces 1
million et demi d'usagers des transports
vital pour tout l'est parisien
une fois de plus délaissée par rapport à
la capitale et à l'ouest parisien
une demande qui touche au respect de la
loi et au respect des engagements pris
par m
la parole terme analyse de l'écologie
développement durable de l'énergie
si la présidente michèle députés
mesdames et messieurs les les députés
merci de vous impliquer aussi fortement
avec l'ensemble des élus de ce
territoire à la réalisation de cette
infrastructure tafer importante 1 qui
s'élève je le rappelle à 32 milliards
d'euros et je voulais vous dire que le
gouvernement accorde une très grande
importance à la question des
interconnexions quand vous venez de le
souligner d'une part parce que
l'efficacité du système de transport
dépens en définition de la qualité des
correspondances et d'autre part parce
que la desserte du territoire est très
directement liée à l'existence de ces
connexions entre les réseaux
c'est particulièrement vrai pour la
grande couronne dont les accès au grand
paris express se feront par les
correspondances entre ces derniers et
les lignes de rer et de transilien
j'en viens à la gare qui vous est chère
celle de bris villiers champigny qui
doit donc assurer le lien entre la ligne
15 sud du grand paris et le rer e
cette gare présente la particularité
d'être une gare nouvelle qui nécessite
donc un certain nombre d'études qui
seront conduites sous l'égide du stif et
par sncf réseau en lien avec la société
du grand paris
ces études sont bien engagées je voulais
vous rassurer sur ce point et sans mener
en cohérence avec celle du ray 1 er eux
donc je n'ai pas vu ou quelles sont vos
sources qui vous permettent de dire que
cette gare a été purement et simplement
rayés au contraire ces études devraient
s'achever prochainement et sur cette
base une concertation avec les élus et
les habitants sera organisée dès le
début de l'année 2016 et par conséquent
les études de ce projet seront
poursuivis grâce aux financements prévus
au contrat de plan état région pour les
interconnexions du grand paris express
si madame la ministre nous avons une
question de madame